great so that was step two good you
access it there okay
step three any suggestions this is where
I'm headed right polygon there's an
intermediate step what do I got to put
on here
I'll there to put the bars I guess right
yes sir so I say this is going to be a
bar graph before it's a cumulative
frequency polygon okay so let's put the
bars on here this 300 to 320 for group
right well I'm gonna have three of them
these are the numbers that I am of
plotting right okay so we said this was
ten so I guess three it be some way like
yeah okay yeah three okay
this parts easy we can finish this off
let's let's put it all the numbers
okay so you should have something that
roughly matches that we've gone worked
out the numbers with carefully labeled
axes Chuck de bazan last step is the
actual polygon okay now that's step four
that's what I'll write alongside that
you might like to add because it's so
easy to confuse the way you draw a
cumulative frequency polygon emphasis on
cumulative okay is that we're going to
join up the corners join up the corners
I'm not going to join up the midpoints
of each of the bars we're not going to
go here and here and here right if you
have colored in your bars which some of
your done which is fine okay you're
going to get a different color out so
you can actually see the polygons we're
gonna draw this is what it should look
like okay there you go there's my guide
my cumulative frequency polygon now the
ever important question of what I
couldn't
why not midpoints does it can even tell
me where is it that we do dip in points
because somewhere is sometimes we're
supposed to do
it's yet it's exactly right when it's
not cumulative frequency when it's a
regular frequency so you don't have to
draw this but just very quickly if you
had a graph line data graph like this
obviously because it's um
but cumulative frequencies just regular
frequency it can also come down that
kind of thing and actually we tend to
expect that you know bell curve
not only do you join the midpoints like
so but you also are supposed to bring it
back down to zero okay now here's the
question right and this is a really big
deal so if you are still drawing my dad
just put your pen down for a minute let
me see if I can explain to you the
insight that I hope you remember why its
corners sometimes
and midpoints other times right what is
the point of this graph what what's the
intention behind it why is it useless
for us why do statistician this drawer
or these might will make a computer's
drawn okay I sort of gave you a clue
right the start of the lesson actually I
wonder if you picked it up
this lesson is too hard right
construction interpretation right so
actually the lines yet what we're going
to do today is how do you read these
things how do you read them okay and get
useful stuff out of it now I know it's
been a little while since you've done a
lot of statistics but what useful stuff
do we read off this like what do people
tend to get out of graphs like this like
what's useful about this learn about
this if this would have done good okay
so you're getting different sense for Oh
as I as people gets what are these
things anyway kind of the clean up
people ok heights of objects right what
what is the general shape of the
population and how do things they
brought that's correct okay but there's
a particular piece of efficient so it's
very piece of efficient that are very
hard to read of this but they get easier
to read off this okay how do we measure
like describe what's a group like you
have three ways to measure the center of
a group what are they they all start
with them there's mode the most shoes
the most comment right there's the
median which is the middle score and
then there's the mean or the average
right now which of these three which of
these three oh maybe I should ask this
which of these three is easiest to read
off this graph which do you think is the
easiest clearly it's Mon cuz you just
look at you says right there
okay modes easy to see here okay what's
hard to see is now where exactly is the
media
you basically have to start from scratch
this doesn't help you at all okay
however on this graph the median is
super easy to see remember you just told
me the median is the middle school right
so there are a hundred twenty people in
this group right so where's the middle
school it's going to be here you just
take this
right you're just cutting across and
then you'll get some height right so
this graph is all about reading number
one it's about reading medians and later
on you'll learn about it's also be on
the other quartiles one on top three and
but making this quartile - okay so being
that we're trying to read off mediate
let's just quickly read off the median
and if you got your rule there and
another color yeah I don't
okay let's let's go it's it's sixty
right actually just to be perfectly
correct there's 120 scores right that's
an even number so the 60th person is not
actually the meeting where is the median
yeah it's between 60 and 61 thanks so
far it's 61 in there suppose that's
where 61 works it's going to be the
average of those two middle scores
because they're both equally in the
middle so you get your rule around you
put it at 60 and a half right and then
you rule across if you don't have
another color like I don't maybe you do
it in a dotted line because that way
you'll be able to distinguish it from
the rest it there you go
okay then what does this line represent
I actually write this in it represents
the median position or if you like a
meeting you break right it's like where
am I in relation to everyone else it's
not I'd write the middle okay now when I
draw this line down which you can do the
second okay this axis here is not about
rights that's not about people it's
about well objects it's about how high
they are right so I would call this line
this is the median score right or median
value Ruffolo
so what do you read on this for this set
of data it looks to me like the median
number one the median group is this one
this is the median group this one kind
of makes sense I suppose it is the
biggest group right but more than that I
can say well the median score is
probably roughly around what would you
estimate that to me yeah 370 I think
that's a good guess so I would say from
that the median is approximately equal
to I mean we're not we're not trying to
get precision here we're just trying to
get in the ballpark it's approximately
equal to three hundred seventy now
remember the question I was trying to
answer why is it the corners and not the
midpoints well what would happen if it
was the midpoints don't ruin your graph
okay I'm gonna ruin my in a second okay
but if I joined up the midpoints I
wonder if let's see how much pink is in
this second if I enjoy the midpoint this
is what I would have
okay now see two problems with this with
this wrong or guy that I've just drawn
okay problem number one I mean in this
case the median actually tends to be
okay the medians okay but suppose these
values were off a little bit
suppose the median was like a value like
this okay now what happens when we go
through that process you're saying well
the median positions here you draw your
line across and you're like what is this
it's not anywhere right it's not in any
of the bars is it is what the next one
is in gamma this one it's kind of
confusing right so there's your first
problem problem number one by doing this
and it's the same with quartiles in fact
if I did draw that yeah 30 position 30
or roughly would be in the first
quartile position 93 the third quartile
you look at later but they they map to
something which is just floating out in
midair okay it's problem number one
problem number two years have a look at
the end right have a look at the highest
score okay now if I said well the 120th
person up here it has the highest height
when I read this green graph the wrong
graph what does it tell us that this 120
person the tallest Society had between
objects right how tall does it tell us
that that object is or you go across and
you're like well that's halfway between
425 and 450 right it me miss
so I thought getting the doors open I
think it's latched and they do Don
I just sudden anyway that's it all right
Kiki see what's happening here right
apparently according to this graph the
tallest object is because we drew it to
the midpoint right it's nowhere near the
maximum height right and this diet
doesn't tell us where that person is
where the person in this group actually
is but common sense would tell you it
should be further along like I'd expect
them to be sort of distributed
throughout this group now I'm trying to
estimate yeah
whereas if I draw the midpoints you're
stuck you'll never get past halfway of
this bar graph oh yeah I heard that said
before you this quarters business I
swear when I first learnt it I was like
some guy just decided we I like Conan
since some other guy likes midpoints
right and so they just like you know
we're just gonna agree to disagree
it's not a betrayal yeah why did I do P
points here oh okay look again again
it's about what these bonds represent
and how the graph is used how the graph
is used so if I were to draw across like
a wine aligned from here right what kind
of daughter am i interested I'm not
interested in the end of that data set
I'm interested in the class symptom
that's what I'd be interested in or if
it was actually just you know four five
six I'm not interested in four and a
half there's no one on four and a half
that score doesn't exist like in the HSC
all the marks are whole numbers right so
I don't want to be between values if
that makes sense okay
yeah so like I said I think I think the
best way to understand it is to think
about this guy think about this process
which is what we're about to do right
now